.
BUT SENATOR HAWLEY, TAKE IT.
WE APPRECIATE IT.
WE WILL FOLLOW IT CLOSELY.
NOW WITH THE MIDTERMS HOLDING
THOSE ONLY 42 DAYS AWAY, BIDEN'S
BORDER FAILURES ARE IN FULL
FOCUS AS DEMOCRATS ARE MORE
DESPERATE THAN I WERE TO
DISTRACT FROM BIDEN'S FAILURES
AND OF COURSE, DESPERATE TO
DEMONIZE REPUBLICANS AT ALL
COST.
GET THIS.
A NEW POLL FINDING A MAJORITY OF
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE ARE NOW
SUPPORTING SENDING ILLEGAL
IMMIGRANTS TO DEMOCRATIC TWIN
CITIES AS BORDER COMMUNITIES IN
TEXAS AND ARIZONA CONTINUE TO
SUFFER UNDER WHAT IS NOW AN
UNDENIABLE CATASTROPHE CAUSED BY
JOE BIDEN.
ARIZONA SENATOR MARK KELLY THAT
HE IS A RUBBERSTAMP OF THE
ENTIRE BIDEN AGENDA.
HE VOTED FOR EVERY SINGLE MAJOR
PIECE OF LEGISLATION BACKED BY
BIDEN.
HE IS REFUSED TO HOLD THE
ADMINISTRATION ACCOUNTABLE FOR
ANY OF THEIR OPEN BORDER
FAILURES.
AND OF COURSE, HE IS NOW IN
ELECTION YEAR CONVERSION MODE.
TRYING TO PUT TEND THAT HE IS
SOME SORT OF MODERATE LIKE
CHRISTIAN SEMINAR.
WHO CARES ABOUT SAFETY AND
SECURITY THAT IS A COMPLETE
LIVE.
HERE TO EXPLAIN MORE REPUBLICAN
WAS A DICTATED CANDIDATE ARIZONA
BLAKE MASTERS.
THEIR RACE IS CRUCIAL.
LET'S GO TO THE ISSUE OF THE
BORDER AND START THERE BECAUSE
MARK KELLY HAS AGAIN AND AGAIN
HAD AN OPPORTUNITY TO HELP
SECURE THE BORDER AND HE HAS
FAILED TO DO SO.
WHY?
>> Blake: HE JUST HAS NO
INDEPENDENCE OF MINE, SEAN.
KEEPS PROMISED ARIZONANS THAT HE
WOULD BE INDEPENDENT.
HE SWORE HE WOULD BE A MODERATE.
A LOT OF PEOPLE BELIEVED THAT.
WELL, OVER THE LAST TWO YEARS
MARK KELLY HAS BEEN VOTING IN
LOCKSTEP FOR JOE BIDEN'S AGENDA
AND APPARENTLY, HE IS JUST FINE
WITH DISC WIDE OPEN SOUTHERN
BORDER BECAUSE HE HAS NOT DONE A
SINGLE THING TO STOP IT.
YOU KNOW?
WE HAVE MORE THAN 5 MILLION
ILLEGAL ALIENS COME INTO THIS
COUNTRY WELCOME BY JOE BIDEN AND
MARK KELLY.
THEY ARE RESETTLING THESE PEOPLE
IN WORKING-CLASS TOWNS AND
CITIES IN ARIZONA AND
WORKING-CLASS TOWNS AND CITIES
THROUGHOUT THE COUNTRY.
I HAVE NO IDEA WHY BECAUSE IT IS
HURTING PEOPLE.
IT IS HURTING FAMILIES.
IT IS MAKING OUR STREETS LESS
SAFE.
IT IS KILLING CHILDREN HERE IN
ARIZONA.
APPARENTLY MARK ELLIOT LIKES IT
THIS WAY.
HE IS NOT DOING A DAUNTING TO
STOP IT.
I GOT HIS RECORD BUT HE VOTED
AGAINST THE BILL THAT WOULD HAVE
PROVIDED GREATER OPIOID
DETECTION CAPABILITY.
VOTED AGAINST TITLE CDXXIII
TIMES.
BUT HE VOTED AGAINST HIRING
18,000 BORDER PATROL AGENTS.
BUT HE SUPPORTS THE 87,000 IRS
AGENTS TO BE HEARD.
YOU GOT TOP LAW ENFORCEMENT
OFFICIALS SAYING THAT HE HAS
BEEN COMPLETELY ABSENT ON PUBLIC
SAFETY AND BORDER SECURITY.
GUYS LIKE BRANDON JUDD AND THE
ARIZONA POLICE ASSOCIATION BUT
SOMEHOW IT SEEMS YOU ARE
TIGHTENING IN THE POLLS.
BUT IT SEEMS LIKE SO FAR HE HAS
GOTTEN A PASS.
HAS ANYBODY IN DEMETER IN
ARIZONA BEEN CHALLENGING HIM ON
THESE ISSUES?
>> Blake: WE GOT A PRETTY
LEFT-WING MEDIA IN ARIZONA AND
SO IT IS REALLY JUST MEET.
WE ARE GETTING THAT MESSAGE OUT.
IT IS MY GRASSROOTS ARMY.
I CAN'T TELL YOU HOW PISSED OFF
AND ACTIVATED OUR REPUBLICANS IN
ARIZONA ARE.
THIS IS A RED STATE.
THE INDEPENDENCE BY TWO TO ONE
IN ARIZONA.
THEY KNOW THAT JOE BIDEN HAS
FAILED AND AS THEY LEARNED ABOUT
MARK KELLY'S RECORD, THEY ARE
GOING TO WANT TO MAKE A CHANGE